subscribe
[Music]
ya hu
subscribe
This kind of school really come,
Apo's Saklıkent is throwing the
man in the
following text his God the
man's plates or
I hope
Azer in Hatay I have to
pull the tripe But you would be God if only
Ela water
shoes Ultimate investment  And the results
God is
now
at his school age. I don't know. I don't know.
He's also a man in Hakan Vatan. He's all a man.
There's a
newborn in the camp. The war interrupted my sleep at a
certain time
[Music],
I had to
leave
this letter for Oktay ID
subscribe
[Music]
this but boxer bus move
Your carpets are made of God,
our homeland is given, the tube that finds the phone, the
internet lamp, there is
no way in the blood, and Aylin Ayla on our nails is one of our
writers, but we
do not know whether God is life as the Qur'an in fashion or not
[Music]
subscribe